[Music]
i wanted to thank you for letting me
live here all this time so i'm treating
the family to a vacation
pro tip a vacation is not a treat if
it's thrown on you at the last minute
people have to take off work or school
or find pet sitters last minute
vacations are [ __ ] anxiety-filled
balls of stress
there is nothing fun about them well i
don't like your unemployed jeans and my
grandchildren
jerry but life is made of little
concessions
i guess this is the tv sins takes off a
sin from rick and morty because it's
hilarious cliche
while has alien parasite headspatter
wall has no alien parasite heads batter
there's no such thing as an uncle steve
that is an alien parasite
and even though everyone else will
immediately turn back into the parasite
when shot uncle steve decided to wait a
few seconds for dramatic effect
how thoughtful i get they need to
address this problem but i don't
understand why rick had to throw the
parasite on the table that's perfectly
good breakfast casserole you just ruined
why would you do that rick
why get off the high road summer we all
got pink eye because you won't stop
texting on the toilet
joe insinuates that there is a single
human being on the planet who doesn't
use their phone while busting grumpies
the pink eye is worth it and we all know
it so it's actually rick that needs to
get off his high horse
or pie road or whatever high he's on in
this opening credits cut scene mr booby
butthole holds his nose while jumping
into the portal but we all remember when
this originally happened pb had
experienced portals many times before
and would know this was unnecessary look
i've been a fan of the pups b-hole since
season one episode one
i know these things having a slumber
party style pillow fight in your day
clothes
maybe you got the first one in time rin
can't afford to chance it but rick
apparently could afford to wait until
now to barricade the house instead of as
soon as he realized these things had
potentially infested the house
also considering how many we find out
there are what are the chances none of
them had already ventured out of the
house i'm guessing slim to poopy
butthole
just pee your pants i did it the minute
we got stuck then are you wearing a
diaper summer
because those pants are as white as
christmas and i see no sign of pee
not that i want to but i've got a job to
do here people it's me
cousin nikki i'm walking here i mean i'm
not i'm crouching the elevator shaft but
hey
i'm walking here still a better dustin
hoffman impression than the one in
sphere
also deus ex nicona nikki was the reason
we found that old nazi submarine did
that not even happen well you know this
episode is really just a clever excuse
to do more interdimensional cable type
cutaways which is strange because they
would do a literal sequel to that
episode just four episodes after this
one i guess what i'm saying is it's
pretty obvious that this episode is just
another excuse to make up wild scenarios
with no canonical consequence and as
someone who needs canonical consequence
to do their job correctly i find this
annoying
and deus ex borah gardener is ex machina
ing a requirement of adding new memories
no don't flash back thing i say watching
this is us
or arrow or the walking dead or pretty
much every single show on television
somehow makes its way into the script
marmalade is served and apparently
self-replenishing as well
considering he just poured out half of
that jar on jerry and now it's almost
full again
look there's only supposed to be six
this number gimmick is fun and all but i
have some questions
if they can multiply this quickly why
didn't uncle steve already have several
new friends at the start before rick got
there
how are subsequent parasites able to
control everyone's mind but uncle steve
couldn't control ricks
and finally a raptor can the parasite
specifically change the part of the
memory that knows that even though
raptor photographers are a thing
they shoot solely on digital i'm having
a blast here for sure but i'm also
having a hard time grasping how any of
this works
here rick use me oh thanks pencil vester
let's just think about a sentient pencil
who also functions as a working pencil
for a second because it's [ __ ]
terrifying what happens when the lead
starts diminishing
what happens when it has to be sharpened
photos hard evidence
and that should be the end of it this
show will quickly shift from this with
some sleight of hand but all they have
to do is pull out an old photo album or
some family vacation
videos and this thing is over i will
admit it's suspicious that summer's only
friend is a magic ballerina lamb that
we've never seen
i find it suspicious that creature that
self-identifies as frankenstein used the
term
only friend when summer just said her
phone was filled with pictures of her
friends from school
nipple x's rick that is my daughter says
the guy who just stated that except for
beth and jerry
all bets are off shut up hamurai shut up
amish cyborg what is this 90s conan
[Laughter]
as per usual would be the goat at tv
sins this living room has never been
this big
also i'm pretty sure there are at least
seven that's racist in here so
i'll throw those in as well also also
i'm guessing every last one of these
characters has its own fan wiki page
and what i'm saying is we should all
find better ways to spend our time
fandom ruins us all
i'm really curious about the multiplying
process of this species
it appears they can just appear
immediately once they're transposed into
a memory but how do they appear in the
memory in the first
place it doesn't appear they need
another parasites memory to do that
because once steve was killed the next
parasite cousin nicki appeared in mr
poopy butthole's memory and we
eventually find out mr poopy butthole is
a real person so if they don't need
another parasite's memory then why
wouldn't they all just appear
immediately this is the equivalent of
the ghost that can kill you right away
instead choosing to show you how it has
the ability to move chairs around and
we'll be right back after these messages
i don't hate a lot about rick and morty
but the blatant fourth wall breaks make
me angry
probably because when you destroy that
wall so casually and so completely you
destroy a show's ability for any part of
the narrative to even matter
ever and i like things that occasionally
matter and we can play
nintendo games nintendo give me free
stuff i'm guessing they just did
since that nintendo ds was not in your
hand you'd set them all down in the
kitchen so you could grab the cash to go
buy more
what is going on with morty in this
picture looks like mr bill's ugly cousin
i get that the animators probably don't
pay as much attention to the background
but you've animated this character many
times over and everyone else looks like
themselves
in the pictures sleepy gary even got a
cool hat in his leaving your pants
unbuttoned
maybe we'll see chewbacca what are we
doing
i'm guessing not getting to see
chewbacca sleepy gary is such a tease
grass tastes bad grass actually has a
pretty neutral taste compared to the
bitterness of most plants
[Applause]
[Music]
so how would you use this washing
machine to actually wash clothes
obviously this memory is fake because do
you know of a single amusement park that
would have this much space between
roller coasters and not use it for
souvenir shops carnival cheat games or
overpriced burger shops
what oh was that bottle recently painted
purple and the paint hasn't dried
because black eyes like that take at
least a few minutes to develop
morty give a gun to the lady that got
pregnant with me too early and
constantly makes it our problem
this message about how our flaws or the
things that make us human and connect us
is actually really smart and sweet and
i'd like to take a sin off for rick and
morty actually having some depth and
meaning but
the show casually broke the fourth wall
earlier so my hands are tied
my wife shot a long time family friend
funny yeah mr poopy butthole being an
actual being and long time friend make
any sense whatsoever
no and you know how we feel about things
that prioritize a laugh over the
sanctity of complete logical consistency
that's right we're the only ones that
get to do it and that's the way
the sins goes
that's like slumdog millionaire now make
sure you click that bell icon
but clicking the little bell icon is how
you make sure you get notified every
time we release a video so click it
but uncle steve taught me how to ride a
bike steve
buttons don't work better if you hit
them harder and foam fists don't make
you strong
what was my father ever done that's so
great school superintendent
big whoop there's only like 800 kids in
the entire county
wait wait wait i i can be reasonable
that time
is past now i believe someone has a
final exam to attend
wesley marmalade is served
[Music]
that's rock glomer but you still can't
be in our van
but by helping punky win tv contests
you're wrestling switching lanes with a
car
shut up hamurai shut up amish cyborg
what is this 90s conan